and mike and jackie we are lucky to be
joined here right now by texas
congressman troy nails
he was the previous sheriff of fort bend
county in texas we met many years ago
riding on air boats during hurricane
harvey but
you all of course are full well uh with
the task of
of protecting rivers congressman thanks
for being here
what do you uh have to say and what do
you make of of the crisis that we're
seeing here
you know thank you griff for having me
and i've had opportunities to visit this
border
michael and laredo i've been to yuma
arizona this administration is playing
politics
with the lives of the american people
it's dangerous
what i've noticed is that this
administration is in complete denial
just last week kamala harris said that
she was at our southern border
that is a downright lie my orcus
gets in front of the american people and
says our southern border is secure
that is a lie i could put him on a
polygraph machine
and he would fail it and so would kamala
the hundreds of people that you've seen
cross this southern border
crossing this del rio section just since
wednesday
if kamala harris and my orchard stood up
here on this bank
i wonder what they would say to the
american people about what they said
about this border is closed i've been to
the southern border they haven't
and they're playing with the lives of
the american people and it's dangerous
the people coming across here are the
ones that actually are waving the white
flag i mean they know you're here
they know dps is here the border agents
are here
they want to be apprehended so to speak
because they know it's a welcome right
into our great country of ours
but what about the thousands that are
coming across the southern border
under the cover of darkness those are
the ones bringing in the drugs the
fentanyl and the methane and it's
killing people
and so we have to if you're going to
solve this issue number one you have to
be
real you have to wake up and realize
what's happening here
you have to visit the southern border
but you got to revert back to trump's
policies
that's the only way you're going to
handle this hey congressman you
mentioned the drugs
cbp put out some numbers yesterday that
the
cocaine seizures 65 thousand pounds
already exceeded all of last year
there's four months to go
fentanyl 7 500 pounds exceeded last year
we had the chief the chief was telling
us 25 million
a week just in this area the cartels are
making on humans
it's not factoring in the drugs is it
your opinion
your belief that the administration is
in some way enabling the cartels to
profit
number one i believe that this
administration and i've been on this
program several times now since january
talking about this is going to be local
law enforcement having to clean up this
mess
this administration the biden
administration is complicit
they're aiding and abetting in the crime
of traffickings of persons human
trafficking they know what's taking
place
you know we talk in this country about
the war on drugs and and we do public
service announcements talking about
sex trafficking human trafficking labor
trafficking what do you think is
happening
when these people enter our country many
enter our great country of ours many of
them don't speak english
right they're going to come across here
they have very limited skills
they're they're they're beholden to the
traffickers right
and many of them may have a debt to pay
so they're going to be in our country
and they're going to be doing things
that they don't want to do
because if they don't pay that bill in
full the drug smugglers and the
traffickers and the coding will threaten
to kill their families coaching quick
before we're out of time here and thank
you for being here with us uh your
governor
uh texas governor greg abbott saying
he's going to allocate a billion dollars
to fight this crisis and possibly try uh
and build a wall if the administration
won't your thoughts
you know it's sad that the state of
texas our taxpayers are having to
augment the border patrol with dps using
taxpayer dollars
from texas up to a billion dollars it's
the federal government's
responsibility specifically congress to
secure our southern border
i understand why the governor is doing
it because he's there his charge is to
protect the great people in the great
state of texas
because our president and this
administration is unwilling to do so
so i understand his point here i hope it
can be effective i'm sure
that dps and they're doing the best they
can to try to address this issue but
if you really really want to address the
issue and and stop the war and prevent
some of these drugs coming in and these
illegals you have to secure
the southern border with a wall remain
in mexico policy
that's it you have to do it you have to
do it now congressman troy nails
formerly sheriff nails thank you for
being here